Let's kick it off with cake of the day.
Please!
♪ Cake of the day ♪
Today it's the Nunchi Jelly Cake.
This is not your mama's jelly mold.
These retro cakes are making a comeback.
And this one was made for us by Lexie Park from California.
She makes 200 of these little jigglers.
I know.
It's gonna slide off.
Check out her Instagram and her website, Eatnunchi.com.
I mean, come on, I can't stop jiggling it.
I don't know if you're ready for that jelly cake, Drew.
I might be, okay.
Okay.
Ross, your story, your turn.
That actually looks good.
All right, let's get straight to it.
Okay, I love this story so much.
A writer at Allure just revealed
that her secret pedicure secret is press-on toenails, what?
Now there's a reason I love this story so much.
Well, because for anyone looking for a pedi in the pandi,
these press-ons go for under 10 bucks.
And you can spiff up your toes in just a jiff.
And I know, Drew, that you have another way
to get a pedicure in the pandemic.
I do, Ross.
Yes please.
And I actually have a live-in nail technician,
because look, I've gotta do a show.
I know it seems bougie, but it's what I do.
It's how I roll, Ross.
Who is your live-in nail technician?
It's my daughter Olive.
And she gave me this pedi,
and I'm not kidding, it's so good, and she's so cute.
And first of all, she asks to do it.
I don't force my child to give me a pedi.
This was all a joke, so please don't everybody think
like I would ever put my children in that position.
You can't even get the jelly cut.
But you know, she was so cute.
She'd literally did this on my legs, and massaged it
and kept splashing this ice cold water on my legs.
I was like, ah!
But it was the cutest, sweetest thing.
And she's really good.
So I have a pandi pedi thanks to
my beautiful daughter, Olive.
Well, I actually think getting a pedicure
is one of those things in life where I feel like
if my feet are together, my life is together.
Does that make sense?
If I have time to go do that, get that done,
of course not during a pandemic, you understand, we can't.
But it makes me feel like I have it all together.
Everybody has that one thing, also,
that makes them feel fresh and alive.
For me, I always think my room...
There's a saying your head is as messy as your room is.
So I keep my room clean,
'cause (sighs).
Yeah.
Okay, this-
That's good, yeah, clean space, clean mind, I like that.
Yes, cleanliness is next to godliness.
And it's already like so wacky in here
that a little, little cleanliness is helpful.
Anyone that's seen the show knows that.
Yeah, that's right!
This story really spoke to me.
Douglas, you're gonna like this too.
Finance News reports, CNBC,
Petco has filed for an initial public offering.
There'll be listed as Woof on the NASDAQ.
That's a true story, not just a cute whimsical nickname.
Petco sales are up because of the pandemic.
Pet owners have obviously adopted more and more,
and have created a $4 billion amount in new demand.
Yeah.
And I mean, I have....
Douglas, what do you think about that?
What do you have to say to Petco?
You look riveted, Douglas.
Yeah, I'm just excited about this.
Well, I think it's great
because people have been adopting a lot of new pets.
It's like 4% of pets are up.
So it's like $4 billion, like you said, in the market,
because people are spending on their babies.
(upbeat music)